I am a Reaver and I was taught how to
pray Salah that means every single time
I pray the person who told me gets the
reward five times a day from F to is if
you want to support someone like me in
learning Salah then sponsor 10 people
for just 00 this Ramadan remember the
prophet peace be upon him said charity
does not decrease wealth click the
button and donate
now look what he says at the death of
this scholar Subhan Allah look at this
somebody's asking him a question and
he's replying saying it depends on his
Innovation yeah should we be happy or
sad of the death of another believer and
not just another believer someone who's
dedicated his life to serving the um if
it is severe and has caused significant
harm to the umah then celebrating his
death is something we should do you are
a bodybuilder look there's pictures of
you you are a personal trainer you
should talk about biceps triceps chest
shoulder moves legs Calis whatever you
want to talk that's what you should I'm
not trying to mock you I'm saying you
are a personal trainer bodybuilder talk
about it all day day you know what I
will watch your
videos brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well in it is
the month of Ramadan brothers and
sisters we are in the last 10 nights and
today might be the 23rd night brothers
and sisters Subhan Allah and I mean
there's a lot of people doing lot of
people doing lot people doing which they
should do Quran I advise this these last
10 nights
Quran whatever it is do it to the best
of your ability there are those who are
getting close to Allah subhana wa tala
there are those who want to make their
sins forgiven there are those who have
backp who have committed sins Z alcohol
R who like I want to change my ways and
not go back then there is FIS then there
are all these people and then there's
FIS so to myself obviously I want to be
careful because like I said before guys
I don't I dislike this person for the
sake of Allah yeah and I ask Allah T to
deal with him not because I have
anything personal with him he's done
nothing personal he hasn't sto my money
he hasn't sted he hased my wife or my
mom or my children he's done nothing to
me not not that I remember he's ever
insulted me personally neither have I
ever done that to him I hate him for the
sake of Allah why because of his um the
way he mocked the boycott the way he's
been um attacking the people in Gaza yes
um and whatever I don't want to go into
details yet okay the way you can see
he's a fullblown um you know I don't
want to call it but you get the idea and
he knows he's on the payroll yeah he
already admits that yeah and not only
that now he's just topped up like I mean
you can't really top you up more you
know the whole Gaza situation and what
they're going for and boycott and you
just mock that now he's telling us in
Ramadan Ramadan the last 10 nights
someone let me tell something if someone
dies in Ramadan the last 10 nights to me
this is a this is a good side yeah any
believer will come and say this is a
good sign we are told that we should
assume the best in the Believers okay
it's a good sign and we know from Hadith
the prophet said that Muslim is the one
whose tongue is free from oppressing
others yes your tongue is free from
oppressing other Muslims in the Quran he
clearly stat to us Muslims the Believers
are those who are soft towards the
Believers and harsh towards the enemies
of Islam now when you see the opposite
the opposite where somebody is soft
towards the enemies of Islam who are
harsh towards the Muslims this reminds
me of a specific group and I give a
disclaimer I am not saying his because
that make me an ignorant person I am not
qualified to deem anyone to be this
group or that group because I know my
Lane I know who I am and I know my lane
and believe me it is for those people
who are high Scholars who can make this
judgment and even even if they make that
judgment if another scholar comes and
says no he's not an innovator then there
is principles in place to distinguish
that you cannot come and say this person
is an outright innovator because one
scholar can deem him to be another might
not be so we know what clearart
Innovation is however when you are not
qualified you will make statements like
this I just want to read it to you guys
because to me it is absolutely shocking
what I saw he's basically asking us to
be happy about the death of someone who
has served the umah brother and sisters
yes I just want to obviously correct
the's name is Abu is Al yes okay this is
somebody Subhan Allah who has served for
years on end you've seen his friend
who's heard the news of his death crying
yes and the Muslims should be upset and
sad but no not Faris and his crew
because they have no mercy for the
people in Gaza do you really think he's
going to come and have mercy on a
scholar who served the dean and based on
him him that he's an innovator look at
this guys it makes me sick I want to
read it for you guys okay this is what
this man said and may Allah subh deal
with him you can easily become popular
among the masses just tell them what
they want to hear the prophet Muhammad
narrated by that whoever seeks to please
people at the cost of Allah's
displeasure Allah will leave him to be
leave him to the people and whoever
displeases people for the for the sake
of Allah for the sake of pleasing Allah
Allah will suffice him against the
people now he's applying this to himself
you know when someone is really
righteous he gets a Hadith my friend who
said that you are someone that you're
trying to basically saying I'm not here
to please the people and I meaning I'm
my intentions in the right place you're
talking with no knowledge with all du
respect you are a bodybuilder look
there's pictures of you you are a
personal trainer you should talk about
biceps triceps chest shoulder moves legs
calisthenics whatever you want to talk
that's what you should let me I'm not
trying to mock you I'm saying you are a
personal trainer bodybuilder talk about
it all the other day you know what I
will watch your videos I want to learn
please I want get my Bice bit more
bigger half inch please I want to learn
yes I will watch your videos man if if
someone said to me for the sake of if
you changed if someone said I will we
will get I will promote this stuff stick
to body building bro yes okay look what
he says at the death of this scholar
Subhan Allah look at this somebody's
asking him a question and he's replying
saying it depends on his Innovation you
should we be happy or sad of the death
of another believer and not just another
believer someone who's dedicated his
life to serving the um if it is severe
and has caused significant harm to the
umah then celebrating his death is
something we should do it is the it is
from the Sunnah that people of knowledge
and righteousness avoid praying over the
people of innovation uh um and sins as a
way of warning others against them the
the point here is that what he's saying
or quoting from is is the H but my
friend like I said before you're a
bodybuilder this is misapplying it
because you and your little click your
little crew so solid crew little uh
few of you guys you are the ones who are
deeming people to be innovators when
your your Buddy Abu was warned against
even some even deem to be innovators
what did you guys do oh no no no no but
some Scholars prais him okay so when
scholar one scholar says he's innovator
he should be warned against argument
sake and other group of Scholars have
apparently praised them what do you do
you defend them to the death this is the
hypocrisy I just want to read a few
other Tweets in yeah look this this is
what it says this is this is faris's
reminder for the people in Ramadan check
this out you can't make this stuff up
yet every Muslim male and female should
strive diligently in those in these
blessed 10 Nights by increasing listen
carefully in the remembrance of Allah
recitation of the Quran longer prayer at
night and supplication Dua seeking
forgiveness and asking Allah for pardon
you should be mindful of your time
minimize ID you can't make this stuff up
minimize ID and distraction with
permissible activities and avoid even
more so disliked and prohibited actions
my friends you can't make this up it's
like me coming and saying I just killed
someone I just want to give a reminder
to people in last 10 nights do not
commit murder if you kill one say if you
killed the whole of
humanity brother you just K I just
killed someone what are you are you like
are you okay like he's given that and
where is don't back bite don't eat the
flesh some Scholars say that the the
Flesh of the scholars is that poison and
mark my words pH is going to be
humiliated Allah is going to humiliate
him Allah humiliates people like him and
I cannot wait to see this man is my
words take this video and clip it this
man is going to get humiliated by Allah
T the Flesh of the scholars is poisoned
and it's going to poison you FIS you
have broken your fast with the Flesh of
Scholars you are asking people to be
happy Jo like can you imagine be happy
brother I will be happy if Netanyahu
died yes the enemies of Islam died if I
heard them I would be more happy he's
saying us no don't do that he died at ha
be happy can you imagine I'm going to go
in Ramadan in the lasting night in an OD
night and go you know what I'm going to
be happy at the death of who someone who
served if someone told me this and I
didn't fear Allah I would say this man
is a maaf and I'm not saying he
is I would say this man this man this
man is a maaf bro there's the F it
cannot be yes and of course I'm not
qualified to say that because this a
matter of the heart yeah okay we know
the one Subhan Allah um a a person who
believes in his heart and doesn't on his
tongue is a cfir and the one who
testifies in his tongue and not in his
heart is a mafic but this is a matter of
the heart I cannot see but there's a big
question mark on this guys and he's made
a few posts of uh Gaza because he needs
to save his um uh self insh this is this
is what it says look in the blessed days
don't forget Gaza in your duas the
zioners have no mercy and no shame
bombing them in the month of Mercy
brother we know what you're trying to do
no one's buying it everyone's seen your
reality how people seen the reality of
zus they have seen your reality so all
I'm going to say is this cuz I'm not
going to back by you cuz the last thing
I want to do is give my good deeds to
you brother the last person on this
planet Earth here just know people like
you who you know you do you talk about
all of those extra you do you know it's
like Allah subhana tala allows you to do
that so on you know all the people you
back with all the scholars you're going
to give it to all of them all of them
you know the goodies you've done like
Allah says like we told that you're
going to come on a day and it's going to
be mountain and it's going to turn into
scatters you know why cuz you
unqualified you're an unqualified person
and you know that saying a disrespectful
R you are unqualified person you're a
bodybuilder yeah there's nothing wrong
being a bodybuilder I'm saying you are a
bodybuilder you're a trainer okay when
you come and speak about matters that
you shouldn't and it is severe in the S
of allaha because what does the
Christians do they do exactly the same
thing they say Allah has a son you are
talking on behalf of Allah subh tala so
may Allah subh deal with you and I hope
I see the day that I want to see two
things before I die that Allah subh
humiliates you and that insh Palestine
is free those are two things I want to
see before I die inshallah so brothers
and sisters today could be the 23rd
night may Allah bless and preserve you
guys I want to inshallah tell you guys
about a project that you guys can donate
to inshallah uh which is better don't be
happy about the death of any Scholars
inshallah but what you can do um in
inshallah is not to this
one um is this one inshallah is donate
and help teach people how to pray Salah
brother and sisters 100 pound will teach
10 to 30 people had to pray Salah
inshallah I know oh yeah FIS is watching
this B he's going to say ah look at this
guy people to donate because it goes in
his pocket I don't get paid a penny I'm
a trusty and a volunteer sorry about
that FIS your next video might be
different there you go guys this will
help teach someone how to do woodoo
we've got woodoo guide in every single
um package and inshallah this guided
prayer mat teaches people how to pray
Salah insh and recite F alhamdulillah
and yes and these new Muslims we tried
to teach them not to back by and slander
other people inshah so yes that's it
brother and sisters till next
time um look after yourselves bye-bye